[Music]
my days as an assistant principal began
by the flagpole welcoming students to
school like Roberto with his rat tail
and ninja turtle backpack he was just
one of those kiddos who made me smile
I'd greet students with high fives fist
bumps and as Roberto taught me these
super cool sliding handshake fist bump
then I would usher them through the
doors thinking that once we were all
inside we could get down to the business
of learning and growing up unaffected by
the outside world I became a teacher
because of students like Roberto I knew
that education could open doors
I learned however that a community can
change a school today
I want to introduce you to Mitchell
middle school I want to introduce you to
Mitchell because it introduced me to
challenges I still grapple with it
transformed my understanding of
community and education to get to
Mitchell you go to the trendiest
neighborhood in town then head just four
blocks to the east the spin studios and
breweries quickly shift to small homes
vacant lots and the Dollar Tree inside
the building our students like most
teenagers grappled with their first
essay saying Selena Gomez at break
outside the school they helped care for
little siblings worried about the
deportation of a family member
drug
sometimes to find food in an area with
no grocery store my kids carried trauma
and uncertainties with them that I the
adult had never known
Mitchell taught me that the brick walls
of a school building
do not make a fortress schools and their
surrounding communities are constantly
shaping and being shaped by one another
with Mitchell as our model let's zoom
out where is the opportunity gap in
American schools we know that if high
school graduates who grew up in poverty
14% only will graduate college within
eight years we know that third grade
reading scores are used to predict
future needed prison capacity now let's
zoom in to our current home Palo Alto
the green represents wealth a to Vinick
Elementary School just six percent of
students qualify for free and reduced
lunch a measure of financial need
students here are three point six years
above the national average in their
learning at Los Robles Ronald McNair
Academy just one mile away 93% of
students qualify for free reduced lunch
students here students here are nearly
three grade levels below the national
average how is this possible that there
is a sixth grade level gap in our one
zip code
let's talk about funding when I was a
teacher a rainy day could mean that I
taught verbs while maneuvering around a
bucket to catch water dripping through
the roof recess was on a cracked parking
lot these were the physical
representations of a system that provide
the fortunate with boundless opportunity
while leaving behind far too many
children across the country school
districts that served mostly minority
children receive 23 billion dollars less
than majority white districts in wealthy
areas like Palo Alto property taxes
provide an infusion of money
parent-teacher associations are powerful
and can bring in further funding we must
acknowledge these facts and their
implications at the same time they're
more than just numbers we the people
must get to know one another ed Mitchell
our students brought the staff homemade
tamales chaperoned the eighth grade
formal arrived at 6:30 in the morning
before work to conference with teachers
they cared deeply but they did not
always have the pocketbook to meet every
need our time for school is ending soon
but our connection to schools is not
today's students are your future
colleagues employees and fellow voters
the issues in publication in public
education are yes messy and bureaucratic
I cannot say they are easy to fix I can
say they are not permanent too often
glitzy innovations like a new education
technology tool dominate our attention
these ideas are great and they can help
but the first step is far simpler and
rooted in our daily lives figure out how
you connect to
the community around you and respond
Mitchell taught me three ways that we
can begin this process by thinking about
our place our resources and our
influence let's start with where you are
your place I challenge you to expand the
definition of your community look beyond
you're familiar blocks learn about the
area get to know schools like Mitchell
if you have children send them to public
school don't opt out if you want your
kid to be successful in the real world
send them to school there they will
benefit from getting to learn from their
classmates and being part of the
community their community secondly the
most tangible resources since the
majority of public school funding comes
from property taxes schools and property
poor neighborhoods need further access
to resources find a school near you that
would benefit from whatever you can
contribute that might mean corporate
donations or spare office chairs lastly
how can we use our influence the good
news is that education is a unicorn one
of those rare areas where members of
both political parties can find
agreement across the country nearly
every school board is publicly elected
yet not even one in ten people vote in
local school board elections participate
to support candidates who extend
equitable funding to schools and
programs I would love if every single
one of you left here today and decided
to become a middle school teacher
I get it this is business school no
matter where you go after you leave
Stanford remember that the brick walls
of a school are not a fortress our
communities will shape our schools and
our schools will shape our communities
how will you contribute Roberto is now
in eighth grade I do not know how his
story will unfold I do know the
statistics tell me he has a 60% chance
of graduating high school he is more
likely to become incarcerated than to
graduate from college but I have hope
for Roberto I have hope because of
students like Michael Michael was in my
first year teaching he was one of those
kids who carried a second-hand briefcase
to school in sixth grade
fortunately Michael is accepted to a
local scholarship and mentorship program
that supported him through high school
Michael is now a freshman at Brown nape
majoring in neuroscience and education
because as Michael told me he wants to
return and give back to his community
Michael is the young man he is today
because of his hard work personal gifts
and the support of a community that
carried him forward with our collective
efforts
let's make students like Michael no
longer the exception thank you
you
[Music]